A crosswalk in Germany where you can play
Pong against someone across the street while
you wait for the light to turn green. And
say hello to the newly discovered Blue Butt
Monkey.
Vsauce, Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
New energy calculations suggest warp drive
could scientifically be possible. Previous
calculations predicted the mass-energy of Jupiter would be necessary
to cause space-time warp around a football-shaped
starship with a large flat ring encircling
it. But if the ring were donut-shaped, it may
be powered by a mass the size of a spacecraft
like the Voyager 1 probe launch in 1977.
"So somebody invest this please, now, thanks"
Scientists at Argonne National Laboratory
recently demonstrated Acoustic Levitation.
They use sound waves to levitate droplets
of solutions containing different drugs with
two opposing speakers pumping out 22,000 hertz
that trap the droplets in a standing wave.
The point is to study drugs in an amorphous
state, which is more desireable than the crystalline
structure most drugs take, because an amorphous
state is more efficiently taken up by the
body. But, the solutions become crystalline
when they evaporate while in contact with
a surface- hence studying them while floating
in mid air.
There is no pen.
You're looking at the earliest color movies
ever found. The National Media Museum in Bradford,
UK date the films to 1901 or 1902, and they
were produced by Edward Turner using a technique
in which frames were recorded on film through
red, green, and blue filters, with the sets
of three images then being projected through
similar filters to recreate the colors.
This super-stretchy sliver of jelly is so
strong it easily bounces a metal ball. The
hydrogel is a mixture of two polymers, and
it can be stretched 20 times its original
length without breaking. The developer from
Harvard University claims it's so strong you
can't even tear it apart with your hands,
and they hope to use this kind of material
in replacement cartilage or as scaffolds for
growing artificial organs.
Tallest Mohawk in the world.
These Prototype GPS shoes will guide you home
no matter where you are in the world. Simply
upload your destination via a USB Cable to
the GPS located in the heel, then click your
heels together to activate a ring of LED lights
in the toe that point you in the right direction.
LIFX looks to reinvent the light bulb. Controlled
by a smart phone, it boasts a variety of features
including color controls, timers like a slowly
fading night light, music visualization, and
even flashing to alert you of your social
media notifications. Find the link below for
more information.
Finally, Experimental Light Sculpture is a
BTK College of Design student-project involving
a jagged surface wall and animated project
light. I'm gonna leave you with the deepest swimming pool in the world.
So, this is the 50th episode of Mind Blow,
and whether you've been with Vsauce2 from
the beginning, or just recently found out
about this channel through the awesome videos
that Michael is doing over on Vsauce1, I just
wanted to say that I really appreciate all
the great comments, all the stuff you guys
send me for BiDiPi, and everything else that
makes Vsauce one of the cooles things on YouTube.
So, here's to 50 more episodes, and, as always,
thanks for watching. Also, I'm not bald, so...I
just like hats.